I'm Dan Massey and I'm gonna
show you how I collected venom
from scorpions for a research project.
This process of collecting
venom is called milking.
In this video, I'm milking scorpions in my home.
What I have here is a Bark Scorpion
which until recently was found primarily
in Arizona and Mexico.
The Bark Scorpion's venom can
cause severe neurotoxic symptoms
and in some cases, require hospitalization.
The only way a scorpion can hurt you is
by stinging you with the tip of its tail,
called the Telson and injecting venom.
The scorpion's pincers are
quite weak so if I use forceps
to hold the scorpion by the
tail, it can't hurt me.
In order to collect scorpion venom for my
study, I need the scorpion to express its venom.
To do this, I administer a
low electrical stimulation.
The electricity doesn't hurt the scorpion
but does make it express its venom.
To administer the stimulation, I hold
the scorpion with a pair of forceps.
The forceps have a positive
electrical lead attached to them.
Another wire, a negative electrical
lead, is attached to this tea strainer.
When I touch the scorpion to the tea
strainer, it completes the circuit
and the scorpion receives a
low electrical stimulation.
Right now, there's no stimulation applied
to the scorpion but when I touch it
to the tea strainer, it completes
the circuit and expresses its venom.
Since I do not wish to harm the
scorpion with increased electricity,
agitating it also helps express venom.
As the scorpion is stimulated, you can
see the tail pulsate and a tiny drop
of venom expressed from the Telson.
I have a capillary tube in my other hand so I
can collect the venom as it's being expressed.
By the way, the forceps don't hurt the
scorpion, it's exoskeleton is very tough.
A scorpion only releases a
tiny amount of venom at a time.
It doesn't need to release more because
the venom works so well on its prey.
You can see it takes a lot of patience
to milk scorpions and have it done
in your home in an understanding family.
I have more than 100 scorpions in my
home and my wife helped collect them all.
We collected the scorpions from
the state part in New Mexico
where the Bark scorpions
were previously undocumented.
I wanted to obtain their venom so we could study
this new population of scorpions and compare it
with populations of the same species.
To do my research, I had to milk each
scorpion twice, three weeks apart.
After being milked, the scorpion
needs around 2-3 weeks
to regenerate its supply
of venom and a meal or two.
It may only take a single
sting from a bark scorpion
to cause neurotoxic symptoms in a human.
To do research on scorpion venom,
you needed as much venom as possible
to successfully perform experiments.
That's why I had to milk more
than 100 scorpions more than once
to get enough venom for the study.
Here's another view of the
scorpion being milked.
See how the tail pulses with the stimulation
and how only a tiny drop of venom comes out.
And how I capture the venom
with a capillary tube.
The most striking results of my
research were that the scorpions found
in New Mexico were twice as
toxic as those from Arizona.
And antivenom reverses the effects of
venom better in the New Mexico scorpions
than in the Arizona scorpions even though
the two populations are the same species.
In other words, it would only take about half
as much New Mexico scorpion venom compared
to the Arizona scorpion venom
to create the same symptoms.
Also, it would only require half as much
antivenom for the New Mexico scorpion compared
to the Arizona scorpion to reverse the symptoms.
These findings prove the need
for antivenom in New Mexico
that might someday save a child's life.
So now I'm interested in toxicology
and possibly venom research.
The study showed an isolated population
of Bark scorpion being twice as potent
as the large diverse population of the
same species and antivenom which seems
to reverse the venom's effects
better even though it's more toxic.
Why? Well, it's like everything in science.
One answer leads to another question.
But what can I say?
I love science.